(audience applauding)
- It is so great to meet you!
- It is amazing to meet you!
Can I just say from me
and all of Texas, you are
doing us proud!
- Yeah, I was about to say Texas!
- I am from H-Town, girl!
- Yes, I have a lot of friends.
I showed a lot of Betas
from that area, so, yes.
- [Liza] Oh, amazing.
- Katie, Beaumont, all that.
- You reppin' us right
girl, you reppin' us right.
- Thank you, you as well
with all your billion views.
This is Eric by the way, have ya'll met?
- I know, we just kissed
you were (inaudible).
- We go way back from kissing.
- I'm a big fan of your music career man.
Thank you, oh yes, it just
really began moments ago.
- I heard my little booty
was gonna be sharing a couch
with yours, it's an honor,
it's an honor to be here
next to you.
I squealed back stage.
I went "eeee" so I
wouldn't do it right now.
- [Kelly] So how did you
get started on YouTube and
even more so how do you
get billions of views?
I'm just asking for a friend.
- Yeah, well, other than
keeping it on loop in the
background of my house at all
times, I started originally
on Vine, so it was six second
long videos that I was making.
Rest in Peace, I pour
one out every time man.
Girl, my resume disappeared on that app.
So, I went on over into YouTube
because I can talk a lot
longer than that.
My first YouTube video was
twelve minutes long and now
I'm making 22 minute, half
hour TV show on YouTube.
- And you're killing it.
(applause)
- Are you big into YouTube?
- I am making a 22 minute,
half hour comedy, but the
YouTube, I'm elderly so I've
learned all about YouTube
through my boy.
- Wait you don't go down the rabbit hole?
- What?
You don't watch puppy
videos and cat videos?
You don't watch people eating?
- I go to my son's room
and that's all they watch.
They're not watching
television shows unless it's
on YouTube so you're exactly
where you need to be.
- That's where the billions of views are.
- How old's your son?
- He's 17.
- Oh, that's my demographic.
Tell him thank you for watching.
- [Eric] I sure will.
- You left college to make
YouTube videos so exactly how
excited were your parents about this?
- They were the ones that
actually encouraged me to pursue
my dreams and move out to
L.A. so, I know, right?
I had the blessing of a brown parent.
You know, that don't happen everyday.
No.
I did, I did.
So my dad and my mom
actually met in theater class
in college and my dad
was told he would only be
stereotype cast as a brown
man and now here I am being
a brown girl doing all the
things, doing it for him.
I'm so proud to represent.
- That's so cool. That
must be where you get
your talent from.
Both of them are like well...
- Yes, that's what they like to say.
My sister says I stole her personality.
- My sister and I are
identical so I didn't steal
anything Lisa.
Who's like your favorite
person you've ever had on
your YouTube channel?
- Lucky enough I had, Barack
Obama, president Barack Obama
(applause)
on my YouTube Channel.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- I know he's big into the YouTube.
- That's amazing.
What was that like?
Were you nervous?
- Oh, so nervous.
The man walked into the
room and he smelled like all
types of pumpkin spice fall
candles like every candle,
every dryer sheet known to man,
that's what he smells like.
- [Kelly] Oh my god.
- Did he play himself?
- He played himself
- 'Cause I was gonna say,
I'd love to see him playing
somebody else.
- He played the president and
he did the role really well.
- Yes, imagine that.
- Yeah.
(laughter)
(applause)
- So explain though When We All
vote campaign, what is that?
- So I am a part of the,
basically me meeting Mr. President
Barack Obama, was kind of
like my audition to work with
Miss Michelle Obama, our First Lady.
- Oh my gosh.
- So I'm gonna be working
with her for the When We All
Vote campaign and I'm part
of her voting squad to
kind of get my audience and
get my youngsters out there to
go out there and empower them
to use their voice and vote.
- Awesome.
- You gotta vote.
Every camera, go vote.
- Tell me about Liza on demand.
74 million people, oh my
god, 74 million people saw
season two's first episode.
I can't even get the number
out because it's so insane.
That's insane.
- Thank your son again for me.
- Yeah I will.
- Like, wow!
- Wild. Wild.
- I had a hard time getting
that information out because
it's insane.
- I know, it's absolutely gnarly I'm so...
- Would you mention Will
and Grace to them please?
- Yes I got you.
- Just a few of them.
- At the end of the video be
like, make sure you check out
the season of Will and Grace,
link in mio, swipe up now.
- [Kelly] That is amazing.
Do you just get everywhere
you go then, it must be
everywhere you go, people
are just like, "Oh my gosh!"
- It's pretty wild.
People say "Hey," but I love
meeting them and I'm like
thank you so much for watching.
I don't know, it's wild.
Its hard to fathom that many people.
- Well, you're a blessing,
you're authentic, you're cool,
that's why it's reading very well.
So I'm very happy.
- Kelly Clarkson called me cool.
(applause)
- [Kelly] I'm gonna support.
- Thank you.
- Check out season 2 of Liza
On Demand, or don't, she's
doing great.
Streaming on YouTube ya'll.